j'ai été déposé plainte donc en
gendarmerie. Oh que les poursuites voilà
on été lancé la procédure à suivre son
cours et une mesure de protection a été
mise en place puisque pendant même que
j'étais en train de déposer plainte j'ai
reçu des menaces de décapitation de
personnes qui prétendent avoir trouvé
mon adresse donc là c'est me décaper de
de me décapiter moi ma famille exetera
donc forcément il mesure a été mise en
place alors il y a un reportage qui
tourne en ce moment il y a des valeurs
actuelles j'ai ouvert les portes de ta
maison et plus particulièrement de ta
chambre au caméra de valeur actuelle et
à 18 ans c'est incroyable on dirait de
bureau de ministre moi 18 ans j'avais
que des posters
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà sous le regard bienveillant de qui
vous savez mais voilà je fais tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est essentiel ici
généralement avec mes bouquins de droit
de tout ça
alors c'est vrai que c'est incroyable
talent Éric Zemmour dans ta chambre tout
le temps
[Rires]
un peu moins bien ces derniers temps
mais quand même
c'est vrai que voilà
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de gens qui dit oui
qu'ils disent quoi mais finalement un
moment faut aussi tu es quelqu'un qui
tape du poing sur la table et qui dresse
la France
aujourd'hui reportage énormément est-ce
que ça a pas aussi fait que les menaces
sont amplifié
et puis aussi les commentaires de plus
en plus dégradant notamment vis-à-vis de
mes parents ils ont été accusé de
ségrégationniste aussi d'être des
personnes enfin il a qui disait que que
des blancs et adopter un noir ça mais
Créon pas que beaucoup de quolibet
d'insultes c'est insupportable que j'ai
pas tellement envie de répéter
d'ailleurs tu as commencé à te rendre
triste tout ça pas triste mais ça
commence plus ça m'énerve et quelque
chose parce que lundi on était très zen
on sentait vraiment que ça se passait
complètement au-dessus du SIA et là
aujourd'hui on sent que tu étais
commence à être un petit peu agacé un
peu plus
vous poser une question est-ce que vous
avez pas un peu l'impression d'être
entre guillemets instrumentaliser
salaire qu'on vous a mis au premier plan
de la photo où vous
créez il y a des va sur vos est-ce que
vous prenez pas le risque surexposé
est-ce que c'est pas un petit problème
qui peut se poser pour vous
instrumentaliser nom que je n'ai pas été
mis au premier plan sur la photo c'est
moi qui me suis mis au premier plan sur
cette photo voilà c'est moi qui l'ai
parfaitement choisi mais non je me sens
que demain entre mentaliser puisque
c'était c'était mon choix d'être exposé
ce jour-là puisque moi je venais
simplement un meeting politique et
j'estime que c'était parfaitement droit
d'être ici et pourquoi il aurait le
droit de poser des questions en fait
pourquoi cette question pourquoi il a
pas la liberté d'avoir ses convictions
donc d'avoir d'avoir je crois que c'est
quand même un scandale alors
ce sont ces personnes qui prône
l'antiracisme mais finalement enfin sont
contradictoires avec avec elle-même
puisque c'est elle-même qui préfère les
pires insultes à mon encontre les
insultes vraiment de nature absolument
regarder pourquoi
élection présidentielle 2020 donc
j'avais soutenu moi j'étais à l'époque
j'avais sauté Donald Trump et donc on a
considéré en tout cas au lycée où
j'étais scolarisé que c'est inquiétant
et on m'a envoyé voir la psychologue de
lycée pour qu'elle m'explique que
c'était grave souvenir des personnes
comme ça des figures du mat' y avait 10
c'était que tu es vraiment le diable
mais il y a toujours eu c'est top
cicatrisation le position et la
dissidence